throughout the week we've been sharing
our holiday treats Lesley untap this
morning yeah it's not supposed to look
like that it's a whole story here so
what is this okay so this it's like I
didn't want a bacon I've been busy
so I didn't want to make anything but my
family was all freaking out okay this is
what I wanted to do this is plan a this
is my favorite Christmas thing oh here's
the Safeway wrappers oh thank you
it's Christmas cake okay make someone I
love that so this is serious
well I made it and then safe repackaged
it for me okay so that's really my
favorite so that's what you want to do
your but my family's always freaking out
because you need to make something
everybody's making something so they all
got together and they sent me this
recipe and I'm gonna make you guys try
it so this is artichoke dip okay so you
think that's okay right
is that too much for your church that's
a lot you can do this how does it smell
Scott it's like vinegar person I thought
it smelt like a barn motel why are we
rubbing rude we should we have no no it
didn't work out I was telling you right
now this did not work out so it's hard
to talk much too much though is it
edible at first I'm like well it's under
that bad but the vinegar but there's no
vinegar in there so here's what happens
[Music]
okay so like it Scott I'm not trying to
be rude here it's okay I agree with you
oh it's a hard choked tip but something
went terribly wrong okay so first of all
doing that there's no vinegar do you
think something is off like do you think
maybe the artichokes are too well okay I
didn't have a lemon so I just cut up an
orange and put that in there and then I
didn't know what spices to put in so I
put celery salt and oregano in this is
where am I
little bits of chemistry playing Leslie
things did combine proper how are you
enjoying it amber still the recipes on
the global news
[Music]